اهلا بكم من جديد اهلا بكم الى الاحتجاجات
في ايران يا طاهر التي تدخل منعطفات جديده
هذه المره جاء الدور على رجال الدين
ليدخلوا دائره الملاحقه من طرف رجال الامن
الحديث هنا يخص تحديدا مناطق كردستان في
غرب البلاد وبلوشستان في الجنوب الشرقيه
واللتين تشهدان استمرار المظاهرات
والاحتجاجات السلطات الايرانيه دخلت على
الخط محاوله الاحتجاجات من خلال الضغط على
رجال الدين السنه والسعي لارغامهم على
التعاون معها بهذا الخصوص افادت تقارير
وارده من ايران عن اعتقال مولوي عبد
المجيد مراد زهري وهو مستشار وعضو مكتب
مولوي عبد الحميد اسماعيل زاهي الزعيم
الرحيل بلوشي الذي يمتلك شعبيه كبيره في
منطقه بلوشستان كما تم اعتقال اثنين من
رجال الدين السنه المؤيدين للاحتجاجات في
اقليم كردستان ووافقت تقارير الوارده فان
السلطات الايرانيه تبرر هذه الاعت
بالتشويش على الراي العام واجراء اتصالات
عديده مع وسائل الاعلام اجنبيه فضلا عن
تحريف الراي العام وكان مولوي عبد المجيد
مراد زهير قد اكد في مقابله مع اذاعه
امريكيه ناطقه بالفارسيه ان التشديدات
الامنيه تسود في زهدان عاصمه بلوشيستان
كما انتقد تعيين احمد رضا ردان قائدا
للقوات الشرطه الايرانيه التي يرى انها
تبث الزعره والرعبه في البلاد هذه
الاعتقالات التي شملت رجال الدين لم تجد
المحتجين كمان نشاهد في هذه الصور الى
غضبا
هيتخرج عدد من الاهالي الى الشارع احتجاجا
على الاعتقالات ومرددين الشعارات ضد
النظام كما اشعل وراينا النيران في
الشوارع شكرا راويه بالفعل تطورات ما يحدث
في الداخل الايرانيه عكس او تنعكس خارجا
ونتحدث هنا على الصعيد الدولي ولكن قبل ان
نذكر بما جاء على لسان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي قبل قليل في احدى المقابلات
وهو يتحدث عن الاحتجاجات في بلاده يصفها
بالاضطرابات ويحملها مسؤوليه تدهور الوضع
الاقتصادي وندره الدولار على الصعيد
الدولي فان طهران بدات منزعجه اذا
التطورات المتلاحقه والتحذيرات التي
تصيلها من جهات مختلفه اخرها من القدس حيث
اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي على ضروره مواجهه ايران كما
تحدث
عن ان زياره بلينكن تبعث برساله واضحه
لخصوم اسرائيل
تاتي زيارتك في وقت حرج وهي تبعث رساله
واضحه لخصومنا وكذلك لشركائنا في المنطقه
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل المتحده ثاني
في ضروره مواجهه ايران وكل من يهدد
السلامه والاستقرار
سبق هذا التصريح تصريحات بالامس للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاص الى طهران روبرت مالي الذي
قال ان واشنطن لن تتردد باتخاذ اي خطوه
لوقف سلوك ايران العدواني اذا فشل الحوار
كما اضاف روبرت مالي الخيار العسكري مع
ايران مطروح اذا فشل الحل الدبلوماسي ردت
ايران سريعا عبر بعثتها الدائمه لدى الامم
المتحده محذره من ان اي عمل عسكري امريكي
ضد ايران سيؤدي الى صراع واسع النطاق
ويحمل عواقب على منطقه الشرق الاوسط
باكملها قالت البعثه لصحيفه نيوزويك انها
لا تزال ترى هذا الاحتمال ضعيفا محذره في
الوقت نفسه واشنطن من شن اي حرب على طهران
في المستقبل وتاتي هذه التصريحات على
خلفيه الهجمه التي نفذتها اسرائيل في
ايران واستهدفت من خلالها منشاه تابعه
لوزاره الدفاع الايرانيه في الصفا
واشنطن لم تتاخر في الرد على التلميحات
الايرانيه بامكانيه ضلوعها في العمليه
الاسرائيليه الاخيره مصدر في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لم اا يذكر اسمه اكد لنزويك ان
القوات العسكريه الامريكيه لم تقم بشن اي
ضربات اوليات في ايران واوضح في الوقت
نفسه ان الولايات المتحده تواصل مراقبه
الوضع وانها لم تتدخل في الهجوم الذي وقع
نهايه الاسبوع على ايران كانت هذه الهجمات
قد اثارت حفيظه طهران التي توعدت اسرائيل
بالرد